hi hello everyone my name is camila
welcome to pi data global 2021 we are
very excited to have you here with us
um if you would like please rename
yourself to the name that you would like
to be called throughout this session if
you would like to share your pronouns
that would be wonderful
if by any chance i say your name wrong i
pronounce it wrong throughout the
presentation my apologies i already
asked him that in advance
just please feel free to correct me and
i would like now to welcome kevin uh to
the session
and kevin is going to give us a talk on
collaborative editing in gypter notebook
welcome kevin
hello everyone thanks for having me
welcome to my talk about collaborative
editing in jupiter notebooks
this talk is going to be mainly about
the past and current efforts that we
undergo to make jupiter notebooks more
collaborative
first bit about me hi i'm kevin yantz
i'm an open source developer and a
freelancer and my mission is to make the
web more collaborative
for this i developed yjs a framework for
building any kind of colorative
applications
um
it processes a huge ecosystem of
toolings that allow you to build
feature-rich colorative applications but
more about that later
what exactly is collaborative editing
personally i mainly think about google
docs
personally i was so impressed when it
was released in 2006
and for the first time ever i was able
to work with my peers peers
back then it were my schoolmates
collaboratively on the same document at
the same time
i was able to manipulate the same
position that another person was editing
at the same time
and there was no conflict everyone just
ends up with the same content also it
has these nice features that allow me
to
have some kind of idea of what other
people are currently doing and what they
were doing in the past as well so i can
see an edit history
i see user cursors
and each user is associated with a
unique color
really there's an open end of features
that you can add in a collaborative
application to enhance the collaborative
experience and allow more and more
people to efficiently work together i
believe that this is the future of the
web in general and i'm really excited
about our efforts in jupiter labs
specifically
so jupiter lab was i think a jupiter
notebooks was was created in 2011 i
think and ever since then collaborative
editing has been the single most
requested feature for jupyter notebooks
and
many people have tried to
integrate a collaborative experience and
this started in 2013 with some google
engineers
uh they however made a complete rewrite
uh google collab or cool laboratory
and they based their efforts on the
proprietary google real-time engine
which is now deprecated so unfortunately
google call up is not colorative anymore
there has been another effort by william
stein
he wrote ko [ __ ] also also from the
bottom up a complete rewrite with
integrated collaborative editing
features
it was only in 2015 when the first
people started to actually integrate
colorative editing into jupiter lab
and now it's
it has been taking us six years actually
more
um to get a product that you can
actually use to
um
build to collaborate with your peers on
jupyter notebooks
i joined this
project in 2000 at the beginning of this
year
and my mission was to integrate yjs
which solved
several of the problems that we had in
previous attempts in integrating
creative editing
and yeah we made it actually uh during
this year we released a jupiter lab 3.1
which includes colorative editing
features
and you can enable them by just adding
colorative when starting your jupiter
lab instance this works when deploying
this locally but of course also when
deploying it remotely or on a binder
instance
in this demo here below you see that
we have a binder instance and it has a
share button and when we click the share
button you get a link that you can send
to other people so this is already a
super useful feature
but it's still hidden behind the feature
flag so this is why
i
started my own jupiter lab instance
locally i have two browsers open and i'm
going to open the same document at the
same time
so i can see the content from the left
right window synchronizing with each
other
while i'm typing text
and
you already see that when i type text
my uh
i have a you
i see the selection of the other window
is highlighted as with the user color
and we also associate a unique username
that is associated only with me
and a unique color that is also only
associated with me
unfortunately we don't have user
management yet in jupyter lab so
everyone is an anonymous user and we
assign usernames based on the moons of
jupiter to each user so i think that's
really cool but yeah for now everyone is
going to be anonymous until we
integrated real user management
and yeah you can basically do everything
collaboratively if you want to
you can
write some code you can
execute that code and the output is also
synchronized
it includes all the
basic functionality that you would
expect from a real call rate of
application for example
real uh undo radio behavior can
i i would like to uh to get a question
right now if you want to jack b if you
raised your hand please ask a question i
try to
answer it in the chat
unfortunately i don't see the chart yet
here we go
um yes this is a built-in
and you can use it right now using the
dash colorative flag just pull the
latest triple lab instance and start
your instance with colorative and then
your deployment will be synchronized
with all the users so you can like here
just open a file
and
work on that creatively you can rename
files everything just
works uh coloratively this is already
um you see we have some smaller problems
here but um this works oh this works
really well for now and we already use
this
this product for the jupiter lab
notebook community meetings
where we have something like 20
sometimes
up to 30 people working on the same
notebook unfortunately when we have a
lot of users
sometimes we have
some issues
because of the approach that we took to
integrate into the existing backend but
more about that later
is this already available
yes it is
you can use it on jupyter help with the
single flag and i think
we can
i will answer the other questions uh
later on
all right this is
it about this demo um
and i encourage you to try out this demo
but why is colorative editing actually
so
hard to implement why did it take us
something like almost 10 years to add
this call rate for editing feature is it
really that hard to implement
and i want to get you some kind of idea
of what the problem actually is when
building a call rate application
because suddenly
you have so you start with
a single user application and suddenly
you have to deal with concurrency
because your application can be
manipulated by several users all at the
same time
so you have to deal with concurrency
issues and here i illustrate a very
simple concurrency issue that we need to
solve
in this example we have two users the
left user and the right user
and they both insert a character into
the existing document the left user
inserts character a
and they end up and they apply that
change first on their local version of
the document and then propagate that
change to the other side the right user
inserts character b and then propagate
that change to the other side as well
and now the other user is going to apply
the operation from the other user
respectively so the left user first
applies their own operation insert a and
then insert b at the first position they
end up with ba
but the right user first applies insert
b
and then insert a
and they end up with a document a b
so clearly the documents diverge how can
we solve these kinds of problems
yeah and this has been an active area of
research since 1981
and so far it took i think almost 10
years to solve this problem initially
and then in 2006 we had the first well
wide scale application using an
algorithm that solves this problem which
was plugidox
and now we are slowly getting more and
more collaborative applications and that
you know probably from work or maybe
from area other areas of your life
um
and ygs is one of the solutions that you
can use to build colorative applications
yjs itself implements the cdt
which is a conflict-free free replicated
data type is really complicated it's a
mathematical model to merge concurrent
actions
and the idea is basically
internally there's a lot of magic going
on but ygs exposes easy to use data
types that you can manipulate
concurrently by other users and then you
can always merge these data types
together
in this example here on the bottom right
we start with a root document which is
an empty document and one user forks
this document and inserts a character a
into their representation of the
document and another user ins forks this
document as well and inserts character b
think about this as a git branch two
branches and now you want to merge them
together if you use git
you have to manually resolve these
conflicts but with yjs there's automatic
conflict resolution and you always end
up with the same content on all peers
this is some of the magic that yes
provides
so in theory everything that we would
need to do is to represent represent a
jupiter notebook the internal model that
we use on top of yj's data structures
and then in theory we should have
collaborative editing
functionality
and this is exactly what we did
we
actually went a bit further and created
a really nice api around shared
notebooks which we call a shared
notebook
and
this api allows you to easily manipulate
cells to insert content to read what is
currently in your notebook
to get the output and the metadata with
the output in a convenient way you can
do all kinds of manipulations but in a
safe way so when you do an invalid
operation you will receive an error and
you have also have type information that
prevents from
you from doing stuff that is not allowed
to do
and um yeah this so far this has been a
really great abstraction that made the
role of jupiter lab itself very easy to
use
very easy
um
much much simpler because the jupyter ui
only needs to listen to changes from the
jupiter notebook and render them in the
interface it doesn't have to deal with
the representation of the shared
notebook anymore
and
it is actually now fairly easy to build
your own custom youtuber ui
to build to render your own custom
uh representation of the notebook for
example maybe you want to use a
different editor all of that is now
easily possible
for extension authors this is great
because for the first time it is easy to
extract the content from a gypton
notebook and also observe in real time
when something changes you get easy to
use easy to understand events whenever a
cell is added or when content to a cell
was added when metadata was manipulated
this is not hidden information anymore
we expose this in a
great interface that is typed in
typescript
that allows you to well now build
features that you weren't able to do
before
and also
you can deal with all the collaborative
scenarios like for example
you have access to the awareness
information which includes for example
the number of users and which user are
currently online and where their cursor
location is
you can use this to render some
additional meta information on top of
your current
local user
user for example in order to provide a
help dialogue
and you can also
maybe provide
custom collaboration extensions that use
awareness information to provide
additional context that is important for
your specific
scenario
and yeah and if all of that is not
enough you can use yours for adding
custom features in the coming month or
in the coming year we want to add
extensive api
immensely and also add a commenting api
and then annotation api so that
extensions can use to
store information and also annotate the
shared notebook
itself so we can provide additional
information
yeah and finally of course we need to
synchronize the shared notebook with
other peers
um
sorry i'm currently reading some of the
questions okay
um
we also need to synchronize the shared
notebook with other peers and wonder pro
what we do in uh here is we synchronize
basically the ygs model through a
communication protocol there is a
existing concept that we call yj as
providers that allows us to listen to
crdt updates and synchronize that over a
network for jupyter lab we built a very
easy
python implementation of a server that
accepts as updates and just forwards
them to the all the other clients but in
theory you could use a different
provider as well for example
um there is going to be a back end
service that you can use to build uh
highly scalable applications that have
very
low
that allow a lot of users to work
together
that scales much more efficiently than
you could
do on your own
and
you could just plug in the shared
notebook to that highly scalable server
in order to provide custom to use a
different backend you could also use
webrtc to provide a completely
decentralized peer-to-peer experience of
your product and this is basically what
jupiter light is doing at the moment
uh you should check it out triple light
by jeremy tulop it's very interesting
what he's up to
yeah and
so far this has been our biggest
contribution to this project now we are
working to
migrate the client server protocol from
a non-correlative experience
which was only meant to be to be a
single user application
you see this on the left we ex the
current jupiter server implementation
expects
that
it only needs to
send
documents to the client and then save a
notebook so there's no incremental
updates that we have to handle the
editing experience is basically client
opens a notebook
you um
you receive back a json document then
you make some changes and at some point
few minutes or hours later you save the
notebook and if something happens in
between all the changes are lost
a true colorative mode will request a
notebook and you get back a y2s document
and from then on you can make
incremental changes and think you might
synchronize each incremental change with
the server itself you see there's no
safe notebook api anymore
it is always synchronized with the back
end and you can be sure that whenever
you close a notebook your latest changes
will be stored synchronized
now there's a problem you might have
noticed
because yjs itself is a javascript
implementation for conflict resolution
we currently don't have a
we currently don't have a python
implementation but python the egypta
server is a python implementation of a
server
and yeah currently the jupyter server is
not able to understand and read the
content of a shared notebook but we want
to change that with the ycdt project
it is a very ambitious project to port
yjs to many many different languages we
want the whole ecosystem of many
different languages to be able to
to understand each other so a swift
application and android
can communicate with an android
application and they can communicate
with a web application and they can also
communicate with the python server of
course
um based on a single rust implementation
of the y2s cdt that we are currently
working on
we are generating language bindings to
other languages like python c and java
and wasn't
and
you can use them uh
yeah to build
they provide all the functionality that
ygs provides but uh the advantage is
that we don't have to
make changes to all these different
ports because all these ports are
automatically generated
once all of that is done and we are
confident that the trust implementation
works
we can use the python package of this
ycdt implementation to build our own
shared model implementation for python
we could even even use the same approach
that we are using in the ycdt project
to port the shared model
to many different languages so you could
maybe interact from a java
implementation with your notebook if
that is something you want to do
and finally this will allow us to
implement a proper multi-user backend
the true collaborative editing scenario
capability in
uh in jupyter notebooks
i see in the questions that somebody
um is talking about about jupiter hub
and you're right that there are
um jupiter hub
i might have misunderstand the question
here
um
so our plans for 2022 is to enable
collaborative editing by default and
make that the default experience in
jupiter lab 4.0 we will actually remove
the non-colorative mode completely and
just expect that everything is
collaborative all the time
and
we want to add more collaborative
features like for example commenting
features chat and version history
and
and allow you as extension authors to
add more and more creative features
i imagine that in 2022 you would have
you will be able to
restrict other users from doing certain
things on your notebook for example you
only want other users to do commenting
and
other users you want to give full access
to your personal notebook which is maybe
on your local computer or maybe on a
server
we want to integrate this experience in
jupiter hub but also with custom
interfaces
yeah so far we have a lot of great ideas
and i encourage you to join the
community rtc community meetings that we
announced in the jupiter calendar and
join there if you have questions or if
you want to build extensions on top of
this
i want to thank you for joining my
session
and
this work
wouldn't have been possible without the
schmidt foundation the alpha p sloan
foundation and cal poly who funded this
work through grunts deck where where i'm
currently working at
and uh i want to thank all the great
people who encouraged me to build this
and to introduce me to the jupiter lab
ecosystem
and now is the time to maybe answer some
of the questions
um
do you want to read these questions or
should i read them i
how do you prefer we have so many i'm so
excited there's so many questions here
and we have questions in the q a that
are open we also have questions in the
chat
so i think maybe we can take how would
you prefer we have seven minutes left in
in worst scenario if you cannot answer
everything here you can go to the talks
channel or gather down to continue the
conversation
yes i i think uh i will just pick some
of the questions from the uh chat from
the question answer chat
because there are some that i want to
answer
and
there's this one question by eric who
says expecting collaborative all the
time seems dangerous
um i'm not sure about that um
i mean
we want to migrate to a safe
collaborative editing experience and
supporting two modes a non-correlative
and a collaborative mode as we do at the
moment
is actually the dangerous part we had to
undergo great length
to um to support a non-creative and
decorative mode without breaking any of
the existing api
what we do at the moment is
basically
we start in a non-correlative mode where
we load the json
and then we have a specific locking
mechanism that forces all the users to
migrate to the colorative mode
and then from time to time you still
need to save the notebook and what you
need to do is to again use the locking
mechanism to switch back to the
non-colorative mode to save the notebook
so really once we have the python
implementation
switching over to a pure collaborative
mode is
actually the much simpler approach and
much safer
and this is not something that is
experimental like ygs is not
experimental anymore
we have many different products using
migrating from
non-creative collaborative mode to
collaborative mode and this is nothing
new this is really something that will
make everything easier for us that will
reduce the code base and make yeah
finally allows us to have true
collaborative editing
capabilities by default
but that doesn't mean that you are not
able to work on your document
as a single application anymore
um
okay there's another question how does
uh collaboration work when we are not on
the same network and how is
authentication handled this question was
asked by router sward
and um
if we are not on the same network we can
communicate with each other at the
moment
we have to have some kind of deployment
of jupyter lab this can be a binder
instance but this can also be
your own server maybe university server
that has some kind of password
protection
we don't really do user management and
we also don't restrict certain users
from joining joining a session so you
need something like jupiter hub to
prevent certain users from joining to
implement to enforce that you have to
have authentication
um
but yeah in in the future we want that
to change we want to have
an option to use maybe github as
authentication mechanism and also use
github to prove that a certain user
is who is who he says he is
or
she is
and um
okay the next question um
what happens when
people have different versions of the
library installed
you probably mean the shared notebook
model this one
we keep this compatible
we have a major version number in shared
models that is only incremented when we
do breaking changes
so in theory like
we can have different versions of shared
model
uh correct sharing content with each
other
but i expect that in jupiter 4.0 we will
have some breaking changes
which we will then keep for quite some
time
by the way the shared model is very
oriented on top of the
json schema for jupyter notebooks so
basically they are fairly equivalent and
i don't expect that we make a lot of
breaking changes in the future i think
the next breaking change that we make is
the last breaking change that we will
make so you will be able to use old
versions and they will compare to be
compatible with newer versions
um by the way i i think i didn't know
mention this but check out this package
chat models is a single contained
package that you can use to build your
own applications
it does not depend on the whole gypsy
lab ecosystem it's actually it actually
has only very few dependencies
and there's some documentation here that
we will also later extend
when
well then i can execute a huge job in a
cell in someone else's notebook that
breaks the kernel
answered
this question comes from eric again and
that is a really good question yes you
if if i deploy on my local computer
something
and you have access to my local computer
and uh collaborate with me on my
computer you are able to
execute cell
content on my computer
we want to restrict that currently we
don't even have that possibility because
you need to have a deployment to really
collaborate with other people
but in the future we want to restrict
access to only allow certain actions to
be performed from another user and we
have many ideas how we can solve that
but at the moment
um we
we don't really allow things that
weren't possible before we just
synchronize content all the time if a
user has access to your notebook and
your current non-colorative instance and
executes a cell they can also execute
and break the kernel if they want to
by the way there is a possibility to use
different kernels for different users or
use the same kernel for all users that's
already possible you just have to select
the same kernel if you want to use the
same kernel but i think the default
behavior is that every user has a
different kernel
um
kevin unfortunately our time is over
okay hi thank you so much once again for
being with us and giving a talk at pi
data global 2021 if you would like to
continue the conversation i encourage
you to go to the talks channel or gather
town thank you so much for being with us
kevin
thank you for having me it was fun thank
you